the supply of fruit vegetables and milk
to Europe schools is on the menu as EU
agriculture ministers meet in Luxembourg
the minister's will hear a progress
report on work toward new rules
governing the aid scheme for the supply
of these foods which have important
nutritional benefits for children milk
fruit and vegetable schemes were
introduced respectively in Europe in
1977 and 2007 the ideas to merge them to
increase efficiency and effectiveness
The ministers will also turn their
attention to the future of Europe's
dairy sector the European Commission
will present them with a report on the
market and if necessary set out possible
additional measures that could help the
sector the so-called milk package
assessed in this report came into force
in 2012 it was designed to cater for the
sector's long-term future once the quota
system ends in 2015 the council will
also examine the e use common
agricultural policy or cap and discuss
how Member States plan to implement key
parts of it following last year's
reforms Fisheries ministers meanwhile
will take stock of measures aimed at
ensuring that fishermen bring all their
catches to land and eliminating the
practice of discarding them at sea the
discard bans one of the key measures of
the Common Fisheries Policy which was
reformed last year and should apply from
early 2015 in this context the
Commission will brief ministers on
member states discard plans prepared at
the regional level with new kinds of
fish stocks to be subject to landing
obligations next year